it's off season and without the hordes
of tourists that usually pack Croatia's
Coastline there's a sense of stepping
back in time just a 15 minutes drive
away the border with Slovenia here too a
feeling of emptiness but this is all
about moving forward
Croatia joined the open border Schengen
Zone as of January 1st and it's being
welcomed here
Dennis is a nurse who takes care of an
elderly lady in Italy working 15 days on
and 15 days off she's been Crossing
Borders for five years
I was traveling through Croatia Slovenia
Italy border and every country had their
own restrictions we never knew what to
expect on the borders this will be much
better it will make our lives easier
enough and this is what it's all about
the freedom of movement no more passport
checks no identity checks no waiting in
line the Border guards have all gone
that's Croatia straight ahead is
Slovenia now it's only about getting on
your way
no need to stop is still a novelty here
Croatia joined the Schengen Zone on the
same day it adopted the Euro which has
now replaced its old currency the Kuno
and for businessmen it's a more than
welcome development cloud has been
importing and exporting Goods since
1995. he has seen Croatia gain
independence joined the EU and now this
for him too it's much better
first I had to do freight forwarding
service in Italy then in Slovenia and
then you went to Croatia we had to sort
taxes and lots of other small import
costs it lasted eight hours sometimes
now you just go through there are no
issues and stopping at all
his son Sandro has now taken over the
business we ask him if he's emotionally
attached to the old currency the kuna as
many people have told us they feel it's
a loss of identity to be honest with you
not much our business is over the waters
you visit all EU markets you pay hotels
in voicing Euros for years we are doing
business and thinking Heroes it will be
much easier now this will make our
business more fluid and our life easier
for many here now being a fully
integrated member of the European Union
with open borders and a common currency
is a good thing despite some emotional
attachments and early problems with
switching currencies it seems in the
long run many croatians prefer
these open roads Stephanie Decker Al
Jazeera on the Croatia Slovenia border